US Vice President Mike Pence's come
under fire for not wearing a mask when
he toured a medical research facility in
direct breach of the clinic's own policy
and advice from the US government's body
for Disease Control mr. pence was the
only person not wearing a mask during
the visit to the world-renowned Mayo
Clinic in Minnesota which is at the
forefront of covert 19 research in the
u.s. the vice president defended his
decision not to wear a mask by saying he
was regularly tested for the virus about
everybody else mr. vice president
ius correspondent Greg Milam joining us
live from Los Angeles and it was a
conscious decision he made wasn't it
yeah seems to be we're told we were told
by the Mayo Clinic that the vice
president's team were informed of the
policy that everybody should wear a mask
if they were inside they actually
deleted the tweet in which they said
that shortly afterwards but you can look
at those pictures and see that everyone
is and you imagine quite a lot of those
people were also regularly tested which
was the vice president's defense he said
he wanted to look them in the eye well
the mask wouldn't have stopped him
looking in the eye and talking to them
about what they were doing it is a world
leader in this work and we know of
course that his boss the president also
doesn't want to wear a mask even though
it is the advice from the US government
it seems to be a case of do as we say
not as we do coming from the White House
and all of this of course on the day
when the u.s. passed that milestone of 1
million cases of corona virus and
another milestone actually 58,000
fatalities in in the u.s. from the virus
which is more than all of the Americans
who died in the Vietnam War which is
significant here now the president says
reaching that milestone of a million
cases is a testament to the success of
the testing that they've ramped up and
at a time when governors around the
country is saying they need more testing
so that they can carry on this opening
up that many of them are looking at even
as the numbers go up it is still a
difficult balance for the White House to
say we're doing well here when when
people are worried and the public
certainly seems very wary about opening
up even if their governors are willing
to do so thanks very much indeed Greg
thanks a lot